[Música]
y también hablamos de salud como siempre
todos los días aquí en directo américa
ya está lista en el estudio más romeros
a la mar con una muy buena noticia una
muy buena invitada que todavía no va a
decir que no es porque usted le va a
presentar vamos a hablar de un fármaco
que ha dado resultados prometedores
contra la metástasis producida por el
cáncer de mama marc quieres arruinar las
sorpresas raúl no ahí está toda la
sorpresa para usted pero si el fármaco
se llama o móvil de hecho hablábamos
ayer de él también durante nuestra
espacio de salud ya se usaba para tratar
tumores primarios pero ahora un nuevo
estudio muestra que puede servir para
frenar la metástasis incluso en los
casos de cáncer más grave de cáncer de
mama recordemos que la metástasis es
cuando el foco cancerígeno se extiende
más allá del primer órgano o de la parte
del cuerpo donde se originó entonces
para hablar de esto y entender mejor qué
es este fármaco tenemos la oportunidad
de hablar con la doctora laura show sé
que ella es investigadora del instituto
oncológico vall d'hebron en barcelona
uno de los institutos que ha
desarrollado este fármaco doctora buenos
días y muchas muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en este espacio de salud
queríamos preguntarle primero que todo
cómo funciona omic funciona este fármaco
buenos días es un placer este fármaco
está dirigido contra una proteína que se
llama mick y se que se encuentran es
regulada en todos los tipos de cáncer
humano
mika actúa dentro del núcleo de la
célula juntos con un partner con una
pareja que se llama max y como bic lo
que hace es destruir esta pareja
reemplaza a más a macsa juntos con mick
y en este en esta nueva forma en mi que
es inactivo pues como me hace esto entra
dentro del núcleo de la célula y da esta
pareja alternativa a mica que lo
inactiva mí que es lo que permite a las
células del cáncer de dividirse es lo
que permite a las células del cáncer de
buscar nutrientes y también a las hace
invisible al sistema inmunitario
y ahora sabemos que metástasis también
es lo que permite a las células del
cáncer de migrar y encontrar estos
sitios secundarios donde puede formar
metástasis o la doctora muy buen día la
saludo desde bogotá le pregunta entonces
es qué ventajas puede ofrecer este
fármaco respecto a otros tratamientos
bueno una cosa que hemos notado y que
nos hace mucha ilusión es que este
fármaco parece tener muy pocos efectos
secundarios en tejidos normales
normalmente estamos acostumbrados en
oncología a un precio muy alto de la
cura y normalmente los pacientes
tienen muchos efectos secundarios
asociados a las terapias y en este caso
parece como podría ser un poco más
amable un poco más gentil en este en
este contexto este fármaco doctora
todavía no ha sido probado en humanos
para la metástasis y para el cáncer de
mama sólo en cultivos y en ratones
modificados genéticamente es importante
también recordar para saber en qué fase
estamos entonces qué pasos se tienen que
dar para que finalmente podamos estar
hablando de un nuevo tratamiento para
pacientes de cáncer
la buena noticia es que normalmente
entre los resultados del laboratorio y
los resultados clínicos pasa mucho
tiempo en este caso esperemos que no
pase mucho tiempo porque el fármaco se
está ya ensayando en humanos en este
momento está en ensayo clínico que se
llama de fase 1 una fase muy inicial
donde se está comprobando su seguridad
en pacientes entonces se está utilizando
primero cuando se es muy baja y luego
esta dosis se aumenta hasta llegar a una
dosis eficaz y segura que se podrá
ampliar muchos más pacientes para
comprobar la eficacia estos pacientes ya
presentan tumores muy avanzados entonces
metástasis pues a nosotros nos hace
particularmente ilusión los resultados
que estamos consiguiendo en el
laboratorio porque prometen muy bien
para lo que podríamos esperar en
pacientes claramente doctora le quiero
preguntar también si este fármaco podría
servir para tratar al mejor otro tipo de
cáncer
si la metástasis es un evento común a
muchos tipos de cáncer diferente de
hecho el ensayo clínico que se está
llevando a cabo no está dirigido al
cáncer de mama en particular es un
ensayo que está abierto a varios tipos
de cánceres diferentes las indicaciones
específicas se decidirán
probablemente este año pero
el cáncer de mama trípoli negativo para
nosotros era algo muy importante para
comprobar porque es uno de los tipos de
cánceres que en este momento tiene
muchísimas necesidades terapéuticas
doctora este este fármaco momic no es
fruto de un día sino que ha tardado
muchos años en poder desarrollarlo
quería preguntarle como conclusión
también qué lecciones podemos extraer
del tiempo de los recursos que se
necesitan para dar con esos avances
científicos que permiten una mejor vida
a todos nosotros
muchas gracias por subrayar lo porque
este no es un resultado que se consigue
de un día para el otro yo empecé a
trabajar en esto hace más de 20 años
cuando era todavía un estudiante y
cuando sé
para ser pioneros en cosas nuevas
claramente se encuentran muchas muchas
más obstáculos no muchos más obstáculos
en el camino y en este caso
atacarla a mí que se pensaba que fuera
absolutamente imposible que podía ayer
pues lleva muchísimos efectos
secundarios todos los dogmas que verdad
nosotros probamos que no eran verdaderos
entonces lo que recomiendo a todo el
mundo es de ser perseverantes de creer
en los proyectos hasta el final hasta
que estos proyectos fracasen de verdad
tenemos todavía una esperanza y en este
caso nosotros tenemos mucha ilusión de
ver que este fármaco por fin está
llegando a los pacientes
doctora pues muchas gracias por estar
con nosotras en este espacio de salud y
por hablarnos de este avance que
seguiremos con muchísima atención
doctora muchísimas gracias un placer
haberla tenido de invitada en nuestro
programa y específicamente nuestra
sección de salud con esta muy buena
noticia que ojalá sirva para curar y
salvar muchas vidas gracias doctora
gracias mar vamos ahora a hablar con
éstas